now I really do believe that the people
here will have a huge impact on the
future of life on the planet singularity
University was founded in 2009 to
prepare young leaders about the future
technologies that are changing humanity
basically all the new technologies from
biotech to nanotech artificial
intelligence that are converging in the
next 20 years and that will radically
change humanity and how we can use these
technologies to improve the human
condition my name is Justine lamb and
I'm a participant and graduate students
program at singularity University my
name is Sheena and Bachchu I'm here for
the Graduate Studies program 2011 my
name is Brinkley Warren and from Athens
Georgia and the reason I'm here at
singularity University this year is to
meet a bunch of really awesome
innovative entrepreneurial people to
change the world in a positive way the
founders of the university are Ray
Kurzweil who is very famous precisely
because of his book The Singularity is
near that was published in 2005 and it
is a best-seller in science and
technology and and the other co-founder
is Peter Diamandis who is also very
famous as the founder of the XPrize
Foundation a since singularity
university opened in the summer of 2009
as an experiment as a start-up
University with only 40 students we have
been growing and expanding our programs
well the team project that I'm on is
called the matter net and what we're
doing is trying to revolutionize
transportation for the billion people in
the world that are in poverty and
without access to good roads that can't
get their goods to market
can't get medicines can't be part of a
participant in the global economic
system so we want to leapfrog Road
systems which cost a lot and create
autonomous flying vehicles and network
of them called the matter net drones or
UAVs or autonomous aerial vehicles
aren't
useful for military and actually can be
helpful for providing peace and Commerce
we are working on because concentrated
photovoltaics Allah says you can use it
worldwide we can use it for the people
without access to electricity people
with access but they don't have money to
buy generators we can use it in for like
the army people when they are going for
campaign in the Western world the kind
anybody can use it ok so our project is
called primer life calm and basically
what it is is a social platform that
delivers personalized well-being advice
for instance a user might come to our
site they might be a 29 year old pretty
healthy person they would be asked to
take some surveys and these surveys
range from personality quizzes career
quizzes information about their
emotional intelligence
so really all different kinds of aspects
of their well-being in addition they
could upload their genetic information
if they've gotten their genome tested
from 23andme or one of these other kind
of companies and so what we do is we
take all of that data and we use
artificial intelligence to deliver a
personalized plan to that user part of
the power of this is that we can we can
match this up to other users so for
instance maybe this twenty nine-year-old
person has a family of three the family
of three all take the surveys they have
different health and dietary needs but
our system is able to combine all of
those needs into one meal that the
person can prepare for the entire family
that meets all the needs of the family
each day when the university was founded
in 2009 EDA had the support of Google
and NASA Ames since that time the soup
the support to the University has been
increasing and we have new corporate
members like Nokia
Cisco auto Dez implant adventures and
many other companies that believe in our
mission which is again how to create
leaders that know about these
technologies to improve human conditions
we're not looking for any kinds of
grants from the government or anything
like that we're definitely you know all
about capitalism and people investing in
the future to make the future a better
place and so
I don't think we're gonna have any
problems raising private funding
actually I think it's a really kick-ass
product and we have a really unique
value proposition and so I think that's
gonna come through they come from the
developing world and now the developing
world is leap frogging
thanks to these new technologies many
parts of the developing world don't have
fixed telephone lines but now they have
mobile telephones the same will happen
with electricity we are going to go from
places that have no physical wires with
electricity to wireless electricity
maybe in as soon as 10 years our goal is
that primary life comm is gonna be
launched as a new venture after su so
we've got a working prototype we've got
a complete business plan
we've met with tons of potential
partners advisors and investors and
we're definitely moving forward I mean
then editing project and in our
company's ignition you can check us out
WWE we are a small startup company just
starting out after this program and
we're looking for engineering talent
anyone that has mechanical engineering
or AI or computer networking or robotics
experience please email us at contact at
matter net-net well the future is
fascinating and thanks to all these new
technologies we will improve the living
conditions of all of humanity and that
is why I'm so excited